Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burns time for the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 24th, 2017. How's it going? Oh, why
are you doing, how's your week? Obs?
Sorry, the podcast is a little late.
I traveled today. I flew
back from Boise, Idaho.
Not Boise. Everybody.
There's an s in there.
That's what I learned when I was
up there. Boise, Idaho. And uh,
and it was hilarious when we, when
we landed, when we landed it, it um,
you know that, uh, the fucking
shooter, you know on the plane,
the shooter and I don't meet with a gun
because you can't get guns in the planes
unless you make one like a,
what's his face there?
John Malcovich and that Clint
Eastwood movie. What was it called?
Gun. Is that what it's called? He
made like that little plastic gun
till I get some God damn respect
and he fucking hung up the phone.
Um, now this, I'm not talking about
a gun. The fucking, the shooter,
the guy, the wedge breaker.
It's like the second they ring,
that Little Bing Bong mean you
can take off your seat belt.
Some guy from 12 rows back like
runs up to the front of the plane.
So of course he stops right on my roast
and I can't get up and I'm looking at
his dad jeans and he was
wearing flip flops. Alright,
so I gotta give it up to the guy.
All right,
you don't have to show that kind
of quickness with like, you know,
a third of a shoe on was
in as it was impressive.
So this fucking guy who was in the
row behind me diagonally across starts
fucking chirping in his ear. It was
like the fucking NHL playoffs. I'm like,
are these guys going to drop the gloves?
I see him talking to
the guy and see the guy,
you know the flip flop guy
looking over his shoulder, right?
It's basically a guy with really nice
shoes and Polka dot socks in first class,
which is where I sit. I,
that's I, I, I don't give a
fuck. I don't give a fuck for,
I'm flying to Las Vegas.
I sit in the front of the fucking plane.
That's just how I do it.
All right.
I spent 20 goddamn years in the back of
the plane. I swear to God I'm not cold,
but they just spill the fucking tee all
over the what did they, what did he like?
What are the odds that I was putting my
wallet on the fucking string to the tea
bag and then this shit's going to
go all over the place. It's just,
I swear to God I'm having a hell
of a like fucking four days here.
Every goddamn thing. It'd be little
cunty thing that can go wrong. You know,
first I break my computer screen
and then the tea bag comes out.
I'm my Jesus Christ.
That's going to take me at least 11
seconds to clean up or I just kind of wipe
it up with my sock. Oh,
what a fucking animal.
I said a stop it from going down the
side of the table. Don't judge me.
So anyways, let's get back to the polka
dotted polka dotted socks. All right.
Fucking gentlemen worked his way up
to the front of the fucking plane,
or maybe he was born into money.
I don't know.
I don't think this guy was because he
was fucking all over this fucking animal
with his flip flops. Who was coming
up from, you know the fucking,
the animal section of the plank.
Well,
this guy deserved debate. All
right, telling you right now,
that should be your guys' goal in life.
You got to get to the front of the fucking
plane and that, that's not a metaphor.
That is it. Literally you have to get
to the front of the fucking plane.
Unless you don't travel that often,
then just, you know, suck it up.
Who gives a shit?
But if you travel a time,
you have to get to the front of the
fucking plane. And I'm telling you,
the only difference between the front of
the plane and the back of the plane is
they just, they treat you like a
human being. That's it. That's it.
It's not like it used to be where,
you know,
there was fucking broads
up there and you know,
they meet you in the Eastern Airlines
fucking lounge afterwards and they,
you know, Gavin like a fucking
whatever the fuck happened in the 70s,
you know what I mean? Is it credible
meeting of pubes that that decade was?
Um,
so anyways,
this guy is fucking in the guys. It
like, I, you know, I got my fucking,
the free fucking Bose headsets,
the wireless ones that those posts gave
me and then I found out this spying on
you if you have the APP,
I had to delete the fucking APP.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
And then I found out those guys at blue
apron are like going down to farmer's
markets. They're going,
hey, you don't want to,
you don't want to be with these guys.
Come over to us. You know what I mean?
What a bunch of pussies, if that's
what they're doing, allegedly,
that's what they were doing.
And why don't you fucking go do that
and a god Damn Ralph's do it in a
supermarket, right. Stay
in your own weight class.
Yeah.
You colored apron,
constant fucking hilarious.
Just farmers Barker guy was going
off on him. It's going to blue apron.
They eliminate the middle man. He's
like, ah, hello. You are the middlemen.
You dumb cunt. We eliminate
it. We farmed this shit.
We're going right to
the people. Um, anyways,
I probably just lost a sponsor there,
but I don't give a fuck right.
If that's what they're doing.
If you weren't doing it,
I apologize to everybody that,
uh, you know, wears an apron.
The color of my balls right
now. Okay. I apologize. Anyways,
um, t spell, can you get to the fucking
fight? All right. All right. Sorry.
I'm a little distracted.
I don't like doing this podcast on
days that I traveled on. I'm a little,
I'm a little scatterbrained there,
more so than usual. All right.
Before you make a joke, God damn,
my new computer screen is Gleeman.
I'll tell you underrated. Breaking
your fucking computer screen. You know,
you take it down,
you'd never go to the apple store.
Don't ever go to the apple store.
The apple store is like flying coach.
Okay, you're going to go in there and
they're going to treat you like a fucking
animal. You know? Nazy
put themselves on a,
on a higher plane walking around genius,
right on their shirt.
What does your shirt
say? Says Nothing. Right?
Like you have no fucking thought you
had and you got to go down there and go
talk to those fucking wire. He cuts. Um,
yeah.
Anyways,
now you got all just
some local fucking place. You know,
they charge a little bit more,
but you go in there. Okay. And did you
get treated like a fucking human being?
So I go in there and you know,
and they see the bus to computer screen.
They know what the fuck
happened, you know, and I'm
not going to lie to him like,
Oh, you know, uh, I got a
little one at home and she
knocked it off the table, the,
you know, doing that shit.
I didn't do that. They go,
what happened to him? I said,
I stabbed it with my phone.
So they start laughing. They
go, why'd you do that? I said,
because I'm an impatient person and
I'm not good at these things. And uh,
it seemed like the right thing to do in
the moment and I immediately regretted
it. So now I'm here to give you my money
if you can fix this. And they were like,
absolutely.
You know.
No, it's funny because I
always have a piece of tape.
I have a piece of tape
over the fucking camera,
so I don't want people watching me
fucking jerking off to porn. I don't want,
I didn't want to watch people meet modern
walking around talking to myself in
the hotel room,
trying to come up with new joy.
I just don't want people watching me self.
That's the first thing I noticed.
I was like,
wow,
this screen is really clean and fucking
big brother can see what's going on.
You know, I don't mind if
they can hear what's going on.
I just don't want them to see it.
So anyways, so there's this guy, he's got
polka dot socks on his fucking, you know,
smart pair of wing tip shoes on and
he's just fun given this Guy Shit.
So I take off my Bose headphones,
you know,
which they probably downloaded the entire
argument was fucking spine cuts, right?
So I take them off and he's right in mid
sentence. Jay just walked right up here.
Yeah, hit me with your bag. What's
wrong with you? What's wrong with you?
And I can't hear what the other guys say,
but this other guy,
the guy in first class,
you'd think he'd say some fucking guy
with a little soft hands, you know,
never worked a day in his life. He's
fucking all over this guy to the point,
the guy who who uh,
you know,
the flip flop guy just turns his back
and doesn't want to say anything and this
guy just keeps going, going and
he goes, what are you doing next?
Are you going to push
down a kid? You know, hey,
you might want to brush your teeth too.
He started giving the guys shift from
bad. His breath stunk. I was like,
I've five fucking love this guy.
Okay,
fucking love the guy.
Just fucking,
just the entire time it took them
to get the goddamn jetway over.
This guy is just in his fucking end his
fucking year and the guy wouldn't drop
the gloves, would not drop the
gloves during the playoffs.
Unbelievable. You know, like
he's some star player, right?
He's gonna, he's gonna. Uh,
he actually hurt the team.
He fucking sits down
the shooter man. You know, I wished
what happened. I wished he grew up.
I grabbed him by his backpack because
I don't give a shit if you have,
if you fucking have a black
belt in every martial art,
um, discipline. If you have on
a backpack, it's fucking over.
Cause all the person has to
do once somebody just grabs
your backpack and starts
running the way and there's nothing
in Jujitsu, there's nothing in it.
Kido, you just, you can't, you know,
that's why if you watch the UFC and
Joe Rogan, I'll tell you this, did,
they do not allow backpacks into the
octagon for that specific reason?
You know what I mean? The backpack,
it's like the gun as far as like, just,
just throws the black belt right out the
window. You know what I mean? You know,
like all karate movies,
like nobody can have a gun cause
then it's just kinda like, well yeah,
I can just shoot you.
You know,
it's the coward way up or the CINCI
way out. You remember that? Really? Oh,
you could do it at Cinci.
That's what I was a little kid.
That was a word that just disappeared.
Meant easy, I guess. It's essential.
Yeah.
Became Cinci I just figured it out
fucking 48 years later, I finally get it.
Um,
anyways,
I just wish I reached up,
grabbed his backpack and yanked it back
past him to the polka dotted sock guy
and everybody just passed him
right back to his fucking row.
It would have been tremendous.
You know,
and I know a lot of ya young
listener to this podcast,
and I could lie to you and say that pre
nine 11 that was the America that I,
that I lived in,
you know.
Well, no, you know,
like you could sit in my house and not
have to worry about somebody from the
Geek squad watching me
fucking rub one out. You know,
in the privacy male God damn home.
I have tape over every fucking thing
I could find. I they can listen,
but the kids see it. That's
the deal. If there's no video,
it's just like the podcast.
No fucking video.
Then my living room right now
that got, I got, I got my TV,
they got the little fucking camera
up there. Not fucking doing that.
I want to look at some fucking pimple
faced Douche and play war of the worlds.
Whatever these kids do, you
know, or the worlds. What are,
where the fuck is Warcraft, Minecraft,
mind head. What is it called
as a video game? Trans said video gamers
to the point that I actually know,
isn't it with witches of Eastwick.
What does that,
what does that fucking game that
everybody loses that by when it comes out.
It's not war craft.
Something like that.
Oh, it'll come to me. Not
well, but whatever. I said,
you just guess I'd get out of your own
stupidity. That's such a great phrase. I,
it'll come to me.
Why didn't I know that back in the day
when I was in math class, you know,
what is the sine, cosine, and tangent
of that fucking iPod news? Uh,
Mr Birth. Oh, it's uh, uh, uh,
don't tell me [inaudible] I, you
know what, it'll, it'll come to me.
It'll come to me and my
teacher. Hey, fair enough.
Then maybe I wouldn't have to go to
summer school. Two out of four years.
I should have gone all three. Fuck,
I should have done all four years.
You know what I mean?
My Sophomore teacher let me off
the hook and gave me a d minus,
and then senior year I was
like, well, what's the point?
What's the fucking point?
What am I getting to a better
community college? Yeah.
It didn't make any fucking difference.
You know what I mean?
It's like when the fucking
outfields playing in, you know,
and then the guy up to the plate,
he hits it over the guy's fucking head.
He doesn't go get it. He
just, he just runs it.
That's why I treated summer
school in my senior year,
not fucking doing that shit. What's the
point when I can go out and get hammered,
drive drunk and do what you did in
the 80s just driving around, hammered,
hammered. You'd go down to the
fucking liquor store. The packy is,
we called it, hey, go down
a Paki. Gimme a sec said,
don't we go down to the package store,
right. And you just stand there out front.
You know the hands in your pockets
looking as conspicuous as possible.
And then you just fucking walk
up to adults and be like, Hey,
could you buy me some beer? You were,
you know, and there was no fight.
There was no cameras back then. The
television had just been invented. I mean,
and nobody knew how to work these
things and people would do that.
They would actually like not
even think about the liability.
They would go out and they, you know,
you try to judge, like get a buyer.
That's what it was. He tried to like,
tried to like pick the right person.
Somebody look cool. You know what
I mean? Anybody in a suit you like,
fuck that guy. I'm not asking him.
You don't ask a mom, you know,
didn't ask any women. You know what I
mean? And she hoarded up a little bit.
You're like,
you then you gotta make the judgment call.
How involved in her life
was her father? Uh, I dunno.
I Dunno now I'm not doing
it then I'm not doing it.
And you just wait for somebody a
little bit of long hair, you know,
some fucking shitty little mustache.
He looked for dirt bags.
Basically what you did,
someone who would have no concern for
people under age driving away with alcohol
and uh,
and that's the way it was done.
I don't even know what I'm
talking about right now. You know,
as I got these fucking helicopters
in my ears, can you hear that thing?
They're like hovering right over my house.
They have an a big parade right now.
A parade or a or something.
It's a, the Armenians,
the recognizing or
remembering everybody who, uh,
died in the genocide,
you know,
I just realized that you're sort of
really just fucked up my relationship with
the Turkish funny boat. I probably won't
be getting any weekends out there for,
well
that in cad Zacker stay on whatever the
two countries are that try to act like
that. We didn't, we never did that.
Ah, that never happened. Yeah.
Well the rest of the world knows it did.
So you could just sit there
and deny it all you want,
but are you fucking Bernie Madoff?
How long are you going to
fucking lie about this shit? Um,
I actually watched this documentary,
speaking of just despicable,
horrible things to do to human beings.
You know,
I don't know anything about Turkish
people, but I'll tell you right now, I,
if they were probably scared shitless
of Armenians, you know what I mean?
The fucking tough people.
That's probably what it was.
They got all nervous or some shit.
I don't know what it was.
It's a lot of Armenians in my
neighborhood and I swear to God,
like every other one of them
you look at you like, is that,
is that a UFC champion?
They fucking jacked.
The heads are shaved.
Every one of them just looks like they
could kick the shit out of you. I Dunno.
Maybe Turkey got nervous.
I have no idea what happened.
I don't know how you
could fucking do that.
MMM.
I don't know. The older
I get, the older I get,
the more a sickening
human behavior becomes,
not saying I'm some fucking sink,
but I still,
for the legs of me do not understand
how war is legal. I just don't,
I don't get it.
You know,
let, let's, let's,
let's wait into international waters
here without really paying attention to
anything. I don't, you know,
I don't even watch the BBC,
you know, that's what a lot
of stuck up cuts over here.
Do I just want to get another perspective?
So Syria gases,
some of its own fucking people and
then we shoot missiles at them.
Okay.
So my thing is where did the
missiles goal and who died,
how accurate are those missiles?
Was it just some guy selling
popcorn on this quarter?
A buzz Syria and a Kazakh is
Stan, you know, and he's up there.
It's the fried pray about it and it,
yeah.
Then we're like, ah, sorry
about that. Sorry about that.
We were trying to get the guy that
did the thing that we didn't like.
We frowned upon.
We would like to apologize to anybody
at the food court. I have no idea.
Our missiles that good. I
don't know. I have no idea.
I just don't get how that works.
MMM.
Yeah. Warren's just really, I
just don't, I don't understand it.
We're gonna murder more your people
before you murder all our people and then
when we win,
we're going to say that you guys are evil.
Okay.
Right. The only way it is if somebody
just starts with you, if they start it,
you know,
then you got to finish it.
I guess that's how it works.
You know what I mean?
Then Sean Connery make a speech about
this and the untouchables or something
like that.
I don't fucking know,
but I don't,
I don't get why we were all up in arms
about that hairless fat fuck over there
in Korea.
You know what I mean?
I just don't,
I don't understand why this guy can't
shoot off his fireworks at his own fucking
country. I mean, we do that shit
all the time. Who gives a fuck?
What is that fucking
durable going to dope?
Yeah.
That's what he's built.
Like it's built like a Jervis.
He just has like a fucking,
yeah, I these adorable,
if you would just stop with the, I'm going
to blow up fuck in the United States.
He's, you got to admit the guy.
He's kind of adorable, you know?
I Dunno, I have no
fucking idea. But anyway,
so I was watching this thing on Europe,
uh,
right after World War II and uh,
then I,
it was so fascinating to me. What the
fuck was going on that I actually,
I went on, I actually
got on my, the Internet,
I didn't have my laptop because
I stabbed it with my phone,
but my phone was still working,
so I was checking out, you know,
a couple of websites and this one
website put exactly how my mindset was,
how I believe World War Two right
after was like, all right. I mean,
I knew in Germany that obviously
they had the fucking rebuild. Yep.
Obviously Japan, hello. It was a rough
one. Right. I knew that they, you know,
we're rebuilding, but everybody
else, I kind of, hey, you know,
everybody was all in a good mood and
shit and skip and down the fucking street
because it was over.
Is this website put at the end of there
was sailors kissing nurses and fucking
times square.
That was it.
Okay.
And evidently it was not,
uh,
it a lot of ways,
like people were acting exactly the way
against the people they were fighting.
It was fucking brutal. There
was all kinds of rapes, murders,
people settle in scores.
MMM.
All Germans that were all around Europe
that it, you know, we're not in Germany,
they will getting fucking
killed and sent back to Germany,
couple of little mini
genocides, which, you know,
between people in eastern fucking Europe,
it was just like Jesus Christ and I to
say some of these, the fucking Nazis too.
Every time I think like,
I've heard the worst thing they ever did.
It's like you literally
can't even watch it.
I just found out something else they did.
I'm going to tell you,
it was so fucking disturbing.
I'm not even going to repeat it.
I can't stop fucking thinking about it.
And then they were showing the Goddamn
Nuremberg trials and those fucking Nazi
conscious sitting there with this
arrogant look on their face like,
well this is fucking bullshit.
Right.
You know,
and then I'm thinking, how could you think
that? How could you not be like, wow,
like the attack got a little, yeah, with
guess we got a little sideways with that.
A plan hub.
They fucking sitting there.
You know what these look on
their face like, yeah, like,
like this is fucking bullshit.
And I'm thinking like how
could they possibly think that?
Because they're prior and I'm thinking
they think, well if we fucking won,
you guys would be sitting here.
All right,
what about when you fire bombed Dresden?
How about that shit?
And then we could just
be like, well, you know,
we wouldn't have done that if you
wouldn't do what you were doing.
You weren't doing what you were
doing. Right. Mister Blonde.
They just done what I told him
the dough or would have been dead.
That's what we were doing. You didn't
do what the fuck you were doing.
We would have done what we did and
then they would say, well, we what we,
we learn from you with what you
did to the native Americans.
And then we would say, well,
you know what, that wasn't us.
We weren't alive when that happened. And
then there'd be like, well, you know what?
You're still alive and a lot of them
are still alive and you're not doing
anything about it. And when we
like, all right, fair enough.
You know what will set some emotion
to eventually give him our casinos?
And the Nazis would be like, ah, you
know, it's fair enough. Fair enough.
And that's it. You should to handle
all his fucking footage of them.
Hang in these fucking guys.
Just a nonchalant way they did it there.
This is footage of this guy. I don't even
know what the fuck it was. It was like,
it was just a board.
It was like a do it yourself.
Fucking hang the guy right in court.
Okay.
They fucking tie the guy's
hands behind his back.
They lay him down on this board.
It just goes like to a 45 degree angle.
They hoist a guy up,
they put a fucking rope around
his neck and he's sitting there
fucking all of them up,
right.
And then a guy with gloves just covers
the guy's eyes and then they let go of
them.
And as the guy slides down,
he breaks his neck and the
guy with the hands just,
he just moves his hand with the guy's
head. So you never see his fucking eyes,
you know, cause they didn't
want to upset people in court.
It's fucking insane.
Fucking insane.
And uh, Jesus Christ, I
gotta be honest with you.
I really wish I didn't watch it because
there was this woman testifying and that,
that, that, you know, if you want to
see it, I can't remember the program.
I'm sure you can find it on the fucking
Internet. You don't just Google.
What the fuck was bill
talking about World War II?
I'm sure somebody will find it and um,
okay.
You got to see them like, you know, all
right, this is just not funny anymore.
All right, let's plow ahead.
Let's talk about something
else. Okay. So I was in, uh,
I was in Boise. This, um, uh,
Jesus Christ, sorry, I'm
typing in my password here.
I was in boy, you know what,
uh, does anybody seen uh,
Joe Macintyre's new shelf.
Okay.
Joe McIntyre from new kids on the
block from the movie the heat.
I got to work with Tom with them on that,
that movie.
And he was fucking great guy.
Absolutely hilarious. Right?
So I was supposed to do a podcast with
them to help promote his shell and I had,
I just completely forgot and he drove
all the way over to this podcast studio
and I wasn't there, completely fucked
the guy over. So he's going to be, um,
I'm going to be interviewing them for
next week's Monday morning podcast and he
is going to give me a fucking ton of
shit. So out of guilt I'm like, fuck,
I got to watch this guy show cause they
fucked this up and I put it on and Lo
and behold, it's fucking
hilarious. It's fucking hilarious.
Okay. I'm not gonna lie to you. I hit
pause cause I wanted to make sure that I,
I said this guy's name right.
Joey Lawrence did a guest star.
I always forget there's too many.
Joe Is in the story so I fuck,
I was going to fuck it up.
He was fucking hilarious.
And the guy who plays is a agent is great.
I don't know what his name is.
I'm on the CMDB page.
I'm going to fuck all of this stuff up.
Everybody on the show's hilarious.
Jamie Denver who I also
worked with in the heat.
MMM.
Who else was in Donnie Wahlberg?
All of these guys were just,
it's really fucking funny,
thank Christ.
Cause I was already sitting there going
like, fuck I fucked this guy over.
I didn't show up. And then I'm going
to watch your show him like, God, God,
what if it's terrible? Then what do I
do? I got to sit there and cross. Ah,
it's a great show that I can actually
tell you it's a fucking great show.
I don't know what network it's on.
I'm going to fuck them
but I'll know by Monday.
All I know is it's not on the comfy
network, but it's fucking hilarious.
Just look it up. It's really,
really well written. And uh,
the guy who plays his agent is
a fucking beast. Um, kills it.
And uh, I don't know. I actually
found it interesting too,
like what his life is like,
you know,
cause it's based obviously on his life
and does so much like creepy older women
wanting to come up and hug them
and now he's got to kind of
just allow them the do it. Um,
I found that hilarious just because I
don't like people touching me. You know,
I just,
after a while I just like,
I so understand how he meant Dell,
you know what I mean?
Just as people always wanting to come up
and touch him and then like what if he
wants a fucking sandwich
and all those hands,
he just shook all that DNA.
He could literally start his own country
with what is on his fucking hands.
And when you really start thinking about
that, you know, that's, I don't know.
Like my favorite time to meet people is
during the winter when I'm back east and
you already have gloves on. I love
winter. When you're in New York,
you know you can go on the subway,
you can grab onto shit.
You can finally hold on,
you know?
Okay.
Just walking down the street, high
five and homeless people. It's fun.
You don't give a shit. Right.
You've got on gloves. It's perfect.
Yeah.
Maybe that's what I'm going to do.
You know?
I've always been looking for something.
Oh look who's here.
Am I being too loud? No, no, no,
no. I haven't done the podcast yet.
Oh,
it's the two lovely ladies.
Can I say a load of my daughter?
What's up?
Huh? Oh, you know what?
The Internet doesn't work in the office
and I was worried I was going to stab my
laptop again with my phone. I
didn't want to do that. Give me a,
let me get one little smile here. Let
me get one little smile. Hey Buddy. Oh,
she just woke up. Did
you just wake up? Hey.
Yeah, it is that smile.
Oh, are you all right?
She's too adorable. And this is not
going to be a funny podcast anymore.
How are you cutie? We're
going to hang out today. Ah,
we did a couple of BS. Nice smile, right?
Oh,
okay.
Sorry, I'm back. I'm back. Um, all
right, let me do some of the, um,
let me do some of the regions. So
yeah, check out our return of the Mack.
How funny is that shelf? Right there
you go. See that Nia would never lie.
Um, all right, let me, let me read
some of these fucking things here.
Where is, all right. Okay,
here we go. Oh, policy genius,
life insurance. Do you have
it? If you don't, why not?
Too expensive or a hassle,
man,
I actually have life insurance now
and I'm fucking excited. You know,
I can't tell you how relaxed I am on
planes now. Now I know that if I die,
it doesn't matter.
Okay.
I have rendered myself like just,
I know I've just sort of delegated
everything out to this point that I'm just
sorta useless.
All right.
Policy genius.com the best online
life insurance marketplace.
The most accurate quotes from the top
a rated life insurance company's policy
genius has placed over $5 billion in
life insurance for people like you,
Jesus Christ.
I want to know how many of the people
are going to get murdered in that 5
billion. Do you ever think
that there is a fine line, Nia,
now that I have a great life insurance,
have you ever thought about often me?
Yeah.
Huh? Why would I incriminate
myself? Ooh, that question. Creepy,
creepy fucking answer.
All right.
Policy Genius is has a very simple user
friendly website to shop and compare all
the top rated life insurance companies
and give you the best options.
They have a licensed customer service
team to help you find the best policy at
the best price.
While you're there,
check out their other insurance
office offerings like pet insurance.
No, Jesus Christ. Just
flush it down the toilet.
Go to policy genius.com today to save
over 40% of zero reason the door is opened
with those dog gone.
Helicopters.
All right.
Oh my God,
she just,
she just put my daughter on the little
swing set thing over there. All right.
Now the tone of the podcast has to change.
Hey Buddy,
never seen a kid smile so much like that.
All right,
go to policy genius.com
there's a kid in the room,
people to save over 40% off
other prices for life insurance.
When Life Insurance insurers compete
for your business, you saved money.
That's policy.com. Please
spell it out. Okay. P, o.
L. I. C. Y. G. E. N. I. U. S. Knit.
I cannot do a podcast with
a baby in the room. Uh,
you knew that when you met
me. Zero jargon, zero sales
pressure, zero hassle, man.
Life insurance made easy. Free quotes,
zero hassle, peace of mind. Don't wait.
Go to policy, genius.com
today. Oh look who's back.
It's our old friends,
old zip
recruiter. They, I wanted
you to do the recruit apart.
You have to know your wife's mad at you
just by looking at the back of her head.
Um,
are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to
find the best candidates posting your job
in one place. Oh, that's not
enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the
top job sites and now you can with
ziprecruiter.com you can post your job
to 100 plus job sites including social
media networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll in to Ziprecruiter's.
Easy Uzi,
easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your
office. Quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why old zip?
Okay.
It has been used by fortune 100 companies
and thousands of small and medium size
businesses and right now my listeners
can post jobs on ZipRecruiter for free,
for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/bird
that's ziprecruiter.com/burr
zip.com/
[inaudible] all right, what do
we got here? Is it only one more?
Oh, beautiful. You don't.
The great thing about shitting
on advertisers aren't you
get less and less than,
it's less reading out loud.
All right.
He looks everybody Helux you're unique.
You don't walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else. Sure. Why?
Or sleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
I don't know. Yeah, it feel
it feels good. I don't know.
These guys give me anxiety like I
thought my aunt, my mattress was fine.
This is a classic sales technique.
Scare the shit out of them.
Create a need because it truly customized
mattress will cost you five to 10,000
bucks.
Who the fuck has that kind of money?
But that guy with the Polka dot socks
does. You know I loved about him.
He wasn't afraid of getting sued either.
Is that on my screen? Oh No. Okay.
Until now. Okay. Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions
and they'll run a three d biomechanical
model of your body through
proprietary algorithms as they,
they developed with the help of the
world's leading era Gomix and biomechanic
experts. The result, like an
exact replica carbon copy,
fucking AI robot shows up looking
just like you and you're like, wait,
but you or me, and then it stabs you in
the throat with the fucking ice pick,
but not before your mattress arrives.
Okay?
You will be one of the most well
rested murder victims of a robot.
Okay.
The world has ever seen the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
How x Helix customers report at 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality?
I don't, I don't understand how, you know,
I guess how you feel when you wake up.
How does it feel? But yeah, it feels,
yeah. How much better I, you know,
I don't know.
30% 30% sounds like a lie.
If they said like 27%
it'd be like, okay. No,
but that's something people would say.
They'd pick a round number. All right.
You know what I believe? Um,
all right. And for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
That's the beginning of the divorce.
By the way,
your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week and shipping is 100% free.
And you and your wife can
begin the slow drift apart,
like the way the continent's separated,
right? Just do it all starts with my Mac.
I want the mattress to feel like this.
I want it to feel that way.
And you're not working relationship,
you know, somebody has to cave,
but not anymore.
Thanks to helic sleep,
breaking up marriages for over 30 years.
Um,
your mattress arrives in about a
week and it's shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine,
oh Jesus, Gq magazine. Oh my God.
Get out the most to Forbes.
Oh,
the bank accounts are all
talking about helic sleep.
You have a hundred nights to try it
out. Graphs. And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free
and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
Whenever I pictured them picking it up,
I always picture fucking Jesse and Mr.
White showing up in their hazmat suits.
Uh, got a helix speaking
of Boise. All right.
Okay.
Aaron Paul,
he's from up there.
Go to hell and sleep.com/bar
and get $50 off your order.
That's helix,
sleep.com/burr Heloc,
sleep.com/pr okay.
Anyways,
so let's get on it. Okay, so I was
up there. I am going to talk hockey,
but I'm trying to avoid the pain.
Um,
I'm trying to avoid the pain.
Okay.
I just thought about
Carlito's way it comes to bed.
I read that Ed Kleinfeld is my friend.
Um, that's, that's one of my
favorite roles Sean Penn ever played.
I fucking love him in that.
I love them with the fucking Perm
and the receding hairline, you know,
he's doing the fucking blow.
Cop comes in,
says all that crazy shit to him
trying to scare the shit out of him.
He just looks at the cop
and goes, don't, don't
fucking hilarious. Oh, I
love Sean Penn. You know,
sometimes I pray for a flood just so I
could see him coming up on a boat just to
rescue me. He's that kind
of guy. Um, anyways, um,
so I'm up in Boise, Idaho, working the
Egyptian theater had a great fucking time,
despite the fact for the first
time in like 12, 13 years.
I had it kicked somebody out of the show
and I never do that. And I told the guy,
I don't want to do that.
I think it's a pussy move by a comedian,
deal with the heckler and that's it. But
this guy was just, he just was, you know,
he wasn't even remotely coherent. And, uh,
I dunno, I offered to pay for his tickets
and all that. I was just like, dude,
you take, you just, you gotta
go, you gotta fucking go.
And I gave him like a one more word.
You could just shut the fuck up.
And he's still is that,
I couldn't even respond to what he's
saying because I couldn't understand them.
And it was getting, uh, it
was getting ugly. It was
getting ugly. So, uh, you know,
I apologize to the people there and
if the guys listening, you know,
just come back next time sober. All
right. That's all. I didn't want to do it.
All right. I'm sure you woke up today
all fucking mad at me. Um, you know,
when they threw him out, they found 14
beers, empty beer cans underneath is a
okay
underneath his seat. I Dunno if
they're trumping up the charges.
I don't know if because
he was in the front row,
a bunch of rows of beers cans
rolled down to him. I have no,
I don't pretend to fucking
know. But anyways, I was, um,
I was performing at the theater and uh,
one of the coolest things
anybody has ever done for me,
the people at the theater
heard that I played drums.
So they rented a drum kit and during
the day I got to go into the theater,
the theater, and just fucking, you know,
put on my Walkman, whatever the fuck
you call it, the iPod thing, my phone,
my little handheld stereo and just
fucking, just rock out man. I had a,
I had a great time and whoever the,
whoever to adopt those drums,
they sounded great.
The snare was fucking unbelievable.
Yeah.
Was okay. It was like a marching, I
don't know what the f how deep it was.
It was like six and a half by
like, uh, what's the next size up?
I'm sorry, it was like 14 by six
and a half. What's the next size up?
Is it eight inches deep? Nine inches
deep. But this isn't a porno here.
People I'm talking to [inaudible]
was incredible,
incredible fucking sound.
And I was this old Ludwig's and they
didn't even have like the usual,
I'm like lugs on them.
Whatever the fuck he called.
The things you unscrew when you're
tuning up and tune it down. The drama,
whatever attention any tensioning the
drama of what the fuck he supposed to say
it. They just had screws that were all
stripped so it's got this great kit.
But to adjust it, I had to take out a pair
of pliers that came with the drum kit.
Um, so it was a five piece,
broke it down to the four piece,
set up the Steven Adler fucking set up
that he fell in love with when appetite
for destruction came out.
You know,
when I was going down the slippery slope
of I want as many drums as possible
cause I was listening to iron maiden and
then Steven Adler came out. I'm like,
this fucking guy's get more music out
of these four drums and half these guys
out with these fucking 15 piece kits.
So,
um,
I just say I had,
I had the greatest fucking time and uh,
was up there with the Rosebowl
tailgate legend Joe Barnett,
who fucking murdered all week
and a Monday morning podcast,
uh,
produce producer,
producer said he said extraordinary.
Andrew [inaudible] was up there and uh,
we made a tour. We did a tour of, uh,
Boise. We fucked it. We got
everywhere. We got fucking everywhere.
We went on the blue field,
we went up to the fucking table rock.
We will all over that fucking
town. We had a great time. Um,
so that'll be coming out.
The San Jose one is almost done.
And then I also got another one
for a San Antonio that's coming up.
So I'm just going to start
doing those fucking things.
I don't know why I like
doing them the fun. You know,
plus it makes me get up and do shit.
You know,
I've been to Boise a number of times.
I never got up into those fucking hills,
you know, so, all right. I think
I've avoided it long enough.
Let's talk about the NHL playoffs.
Ooh.
Uh,
you know,
you want your team to make the playoffs
until they lose a playoff series,
then you dislike that sucked. Shouldn't
they just not have made the playoffs?
They could. He just ripped the
emotional bandaid right off. Um,
congratulations of saying
this through gritted teeth.
Congratulations to the Ottawa senators
and which will allow flight series.
They had nothing to show that restrict
for you guys and your organization.
Good luck in the next round against
the New York farm. Could ranges.
MMM.
And uh, and I got to, you know, you know,
they always do the star of the game.
I mean, at some point you
got to give it to those, uh,
all those Ottawa locals, you know,
there were refereeing those games,
particularly game three, game five,
it even a little bit of game six.
You know, I'm not saying it. If, if you
know, I'm not saying that's why we lost,
but Jesus fucking Christ all I wanted
was a little consistency, you know,
and he has a deal.
A Ref could fuck he in one game,
but you know when it's like three
out of the sex Jesus Christ,
how many times did we have to win
game five before they weighted score?
Like two fucking goals.
If fucking sit in the crease,
cover the puck up in the
crease, not the goalie. Okay.
For those who don't watch hockey,
that said,
I've been watching hockey for 37
fucking years. That's a penalty shot.
Cool.
They have replay. I don't know how they
met. Well, uh, after further review, uh,
where the defense man put
his hand over the Puck,
we could no longer see the plug.
So it was inconclusive as to whether
it was underneath his or not.
So we actually won game five despite
the fucking Ref's trying everything they
possibly could to give Ottawa
chance to fucking win it.
Game three was a debacle,
you know,
end of the third period.
I can't remember the fuck it was someone
on Ottawa just stood up and punched one
of the roads in the face and
we got offsetting ruffings.
We both got two minutes for roughing the
auto guy for punching the dude in the
face and I guess the Bruin for
not ducking. I don't know what he,
I don't know what,
we got two minutes for not ducking
for allowing yourself to be punched in
the face. I have no, so it was also,
I was like, all right, that's what he's
going to do. What I saw that I was like,
okay, this ref is like, it's
going to be even strength.
I'm not going to be a part
of this horse shit. Okay.
I don't know why he
punched him in the face.
Maybe some other shit happened right
before that. And this is retaliation.
I don't have time for you
fucking bullshit children.
You're both sitting down and it's going
to be even strength and no one's going
to know my fucking name at the end of
this, but that's not how it went down.
Cause then in the fucking overtime,
a lot of what comes in fucking
smash is us in the face.
Nash punches the guy back in the face
and we get two minutes ago on the power
play and the fucking business.
I Dunno,
I'm not even saying that we would have
won the fucking thing, but it's just like,
well what, why do that to me now? I got
to think of that the whole fucking summer.
Can't you just let Ottawa beat us? They
were going to beat us. Maybe they weren't.
I don't know. I don't fucking know. But
Jesus Christ, I even thought that last,
that last one. I mean I'm, I'm,
maybe I'm looking at this through fucking
black and gold fucking colored glasses,
which of course I am. I'd love to hear
what you think. Even like that fucking,
you know,
they want on the power play again on
some ticky tack fucking Horse Shit.
It looked bad, but when you looked
at the fucking, when I did anyways,
let's be honest, when I looked at
the, at the, at the instant replay,
it's like [inaudible] was trying to get
to the guy with the puck who's entering
the offensive zone,
Aka a fucking scoring threat.
The fucking Ottawa Guy Turns around,
looks at Pos to knock any,
initiates the contact.
Okay.
Pasta reached out,
grabs the guy and he just sits on his ass.
Two minutes for fucking holding fucking
30 seconds later. Hey, enjoy your golfing.
But you know what?
Okay,
what do I do? I mean I
actually, I have no fucking,
I don't give a shit about Ottawa at all.
Okay.
I go there. I have a good time. I do
shows they've never done anything to us.
For some reason they decided
to trade shower to us.
So thank you for that to God
bless you on your fucking wing.
But now I get this is it, but you
know, something is sad as that was.
MMM.
I was equally happy for the New
York Rangers. Not Cause I like,
I don't dislike the ranges. I
actually liked the ranges. Um,
it's one of the few New York
teams that actually kind of, uh,
I I really love actually love the Knicks
and I love the rangers unless the play
in us then I don't like,
and it's not really even them.
It's so we always comes down to the fence.
So I was extremely excited that the,
uh,
ranges knocked out the Montreal Canadians.
But of course I can not give a hundred
percent credit to the New York Rangers.
Uh,
I do have to thank the fans of Montreal
who were in the Montreal forum.
The second forum on that fateful night
when you guys absolutely humiliated
Patrick Wa to the point he
gave you guys the fingers,
right,
number that then he went over and he
sat on the bench and he looked at your
owner and I've read his lips. He
said, listen, you mother Fucker,
I'm never playing for
you. Cons again. Alright,
trade me to whoever the fuck in Nordiques
are now. And that's what happened.
That's exactly what happened.
He called it and then he went on any one,
two more cups, I believe in
96 and in 2001 or was it 2000?
I can't fucking remember. Right.
And the greatest thing ever is mine.
The Montreal Canadiens
never won another cup.
The end. That's it. That's how
the story ends as a right now.
Yeah.
That's how it's going to end.
I love it that they're dead.
Can you believe this? I'm literally out.
I root for a franchise. It has six cups,
you know, but we wanted 2011 so that, that
gives me, that gives me rights. You know,
whenever Montreal fans talk about
their fucking all the cups they want,
I just started singing glory days.
Okay.
That's all I do. It's really obnoxious.
It annoys the shit out of him.
They started wiping the tears away with
that little hanky say up and their front
sport coat pockets.
Um,
I was actually talking to Barton and
host of puck off and I was trying to tell
him, I was, you know, saying that I was
going to root for Toronto. So, of course,
then they get the old right there, Fred
from fucking the capitals. Um, by the way,
hey bill, who do you think's gonna Win
The cup? I think the penguins repeat.
That's what I think.
I think they're gonna have an
amazing fucking series, um,
okay.
Against the, uh, the capitals.
And then they'll probably
face the fucking rangers and,
uh, who they going to face in the
west wealth full. The fuck knows.
Now nobody saw that four game
sweep against the Blackhawks.
And I mean,
Noah saw that shit coming
fucking people in Nashville, you
know, they actually have this such,
not a hockey fan.
So they actually showed up for game five.
They didn't know how
many games you had to win
at such a cheap joke, but I enjoyed
it. Congratulations to Edmonton.
Who else moved on?
Anaheim and I'm fucking kicked the
fuck out of somebody's St Louis Blues.
You know, I guess I've got
a roof for the blues again.
I'll root for the blue save and fucking,
they've never want a cup. And, um,
but anyways, I was talking to
Bart, nick, Joey Budnick. And, um,
a lot of people don't this, um, cause
the maple leafs have not won since 1967.
And I was surprised when I was going
back one day just going down some fucking
hockey history, rabbit hole. And uh,
do you know in 1967.
Okay.
Like
if you ask somebody like who
the greatest hockey franchise,
the most successful one
of all fucking time,
it would still would have
been the Canadians. Right.
They'd still one the most cups. But a
lot of people don't know this. In 1967,
the fucking maple leafs
were only one cup behind
the Montreal Canadians. They are now 10
cops behind him or something like that.
11 cups, I believe.
Yeah. 24 to 13. In 1967,
the fucking Toronto Maple leafs
won their 13th Stanley Cup.
Okay.
To be within one of
the Montreal Canadians.
So that's like Celtics Lakers,
except the maple leafs weren't
lying about any of their titles.
They didn't win one and some other fucking
hockey league, you know. And then they,
they called it a Stanley Cup
championship, you know. Anyways,
so they win it in 1967 all right.
The Canadians have 14 leaves, have 13
that breathing down their fucking necks.
Okay.
If they went to war,
right,
all of a sudden they're the greatest
fucking franchise of all time.
That's how fucking close they were
at. Once again, they aren't,
they won the cup in
[inaudible] 67 the end,
and that's the end of that book.
It's fucking unbelievable.
And then the Canadians,
they want it the next two years in a row.
68 69 then the bronze one at 70 oh
God. Here we go. This is from memory.
There's so much that was fucking nerding.
I'm 71 the Canadians went 72 the Bruins,
73 Canadians win.
Then the flyers went back to back
in 74 75 and then they fucking had,
the Canadians had a dynasty (767)
077-0870 nine when Larry Robinson beat the
shit out of Dave Schultz. You know both
of them rocking the same fucking perm.
Both of them, I believe had
a mustache. I mean it was,
it was 1976 you watch it now.
They looked like a couple of write it up,
hipsters.
But back then that's what men look like.
And he stood up to him and that was it.
That's one of my favorite fucking moments,
by the way. That's as a Bruin fan.
I love that fight. You know, just cause
you know, I don't know. I, I've uh,
I just don't like bullies. And I'm
not saying Dave Schultz was a bully.
It's like you're playing fucking hockey
for fuck sakes. Me. We do mean to me,
you know,
but whenever they would call the bullies,
so it was just something about it.
Like I just saw him pulling people's
hair and shit and I was just like, ah,
you know, who's kidding?
Who? I love Dave Schultz.
But after awhile you win so many fights,
you just start rooting for somebody else
anyways.
Then they want an 86 then they won in 93
they want 10 more fucking Stanley cups
and just,
they just disappeared over the horizon.
It was like when Lance look back at
that guy, you know when you went on,
went on to win the Tour de
France like seven fucking times.
I still can't believe they took
those titles away from it. It's so,
it's so fucking ridiculous.
That's one of the dumbest things ever
that whole fucking sport is, is on drugs.
They're all on drugs.
So it was a level playing field.
Okay.
That's it.
I'll tell you right now, if they
all at the same people raised okay,
and they all went clean,
he's going to win it again.
Right?
He's the best guy. If they're
all on drugs, it was even,
yeah.
I don't know. That whole thing
fucking annoys me. You know why?
Cause everybody fucking shits on the guy.
But everybody made all
this money off of them.
You never saw anybody give any of
their fucking money back, did you? Oh,
they were so fucking outreach.
Like the fucking cops who run the sport
of cycling didn't realize what the fuck
was going on. You know
what I mean? If someone,
if someone you work with,
if you're in a restaurant and somebody
is on fucking heroin at the staff,
you know the people in
the restaurant don't know,
but you fucking know
because you work there.
Okay.
They let that guy would seven in a row,
blow up the fucking sport and then they
took it away from and then they all kept
their fucking money. That's exactly
what happened as far as I'm concerned.
You know, why doesn't Trump go
shoot some missiles at them,
you know?
Um, anyways, I didn't, what the fuck
I'm talking about? Let me, let me, uh,
let me fucking type in my goddamn
passport. The passport, right password.
All the screen is just so cool.
I never fucking wipe down the screen
fucking animal. I am never doing. I just,
I'd rather squint if for some
stupid reason. All right,
let's do a couple of questions here. All
right. Big Eyes follow up. Uh, Hi Bill.
I listen to your podcast.
When you were going,
when you were googling big eyes and heard,
you mentioned the fiasco that occurred,
which you dismissed,
assuming that it wasn't the same artists.
Actually there was a fraud involved.
The husband took credit
for the wife's artistry,
which came out after the images were
licensed. Love your podcast. I love you.
Go Fuck Yourself. And by the
way, I am a 62 year old woman.
Oh God bless you sweetheart. Yeah,
I actually looked it up. Yeah,
that guy was a fucking creep.
Well we should put a link up to that.
It's a crazy story.
Um,
my favorite part of that story was,
uh,
I forget there was some big fucking,
you know,
one of those things that like
social lights show up to your nose.
People who are just, you know, they
just did famous cause people they go to,
these parties were famous people are
there and evidently only they just have a
great conversation.
You know,
they go in there and they talk about
fucking hot air ballooning or just
something just, I dunno, they just,
people just find them fascinating cause
they can go from subject to subject,
you know, while eating appetizers and
not getting anything between their teeth.
They just, I don't know what it
is about fucking rich people.
They are fascinating idea to take got so
much fucking money. They just get bored.
Right. And God knows they're not talking
to their wives anymore. You know,
they went out and they got
themselves a mattress that, you know,
two different kinds.
Right? Fucking banker.
He probably wants a heated one.
The reptilian content.
So I think, I don't know if it was the
world's fair, I don't know what it was,
but they fucking bought, they had all the,
they bought some big, one of those big,
I'd fucking kid paintings and somebody
in the New York Times and one of these
fucking papers that all these fucking
social lite cons want that respect.
Trashed those drawings saying they're
creepy there hacky. It's awful.
It's terrible art.
The what happened was they just became
to main mainstream and people got sick of
them and they trashed him and then they
immediately took it down after they
think they commissioned her to
fucking paint the goddamn thing. Um,
I mean, what a fucking shame. One
article. It's like, you like that shit.
You like that shit. And then you walk.
Do you commissioned that artists?
She told her how much you fucking liked
her and you appreciated her work and one
little fucking article.
What did you do?
All of a sudden you were like a fucking
kid in high school who wasn't strong
enough to say, yeah, I'm friends with
that snot nose kid over there. Right.
And stand with them. You know, you did.
They just stepped away and they watched.
That lady gets stuffed into a fucking
locker with all God goddamn paintings have
to, what the fuck happened
to her and her husband?
I'll tell you right now that that's
reprehensible. All right. Captain America.
Everybody a Billy Bruce Banner.
I don't imagine you're sending,
spending your free time reading comic
books. Yeah, I can't get into them.
I really like the way
they're drawn though. Um,
and I also like the superheroes
always have like fucking,
they have like the hottest girlfriends.
At least the ones that I read.
Spiderman's girlfriend
was fucking ridiculous.
Jesus Christ, a fucking Teddy's acid legs.
I mean she was, she was fucking amazing.
Beautiful, beautiful God damn woman.
Um, that's why I don't like the movies,
you know what I mean?
Cause now nowadays they take,
they got to make sure they can't go to
fucking pretty now are also the fatties
get fucking upset.
That's an impossible image.
I go to the fucking gym.
Do I fucking cry when Brad Pitt
checks his shirt off? Maybe I do,
but I don't tweet about it.
All right.
I don't imagine you spending your
free time reading comic books, Bill.
But I thought I'd share some news with
you, man. Uh, it was revealed months back.
Uh,
the captain America was actually
a Hydrus by all these years.
Hydro is basically the Nazis.
What?
All right. It was assumed that they
would write it in that he was actually,
he wasn't actually a spy this whole time,
but was pretending to be,
well this month they decided to make
it so that captain America is and has
always been a bad guy.
The story elements,
they are adding our trash. So it's
not even a cool twist. Oh, I love, oh,
is there anything better?
Is there anything better
than the, than the fucking,
the pissed off comic book reader with
the direction they've taken the story.
You like dead fucking Dolores, Clayborne,
whatever the fuck her name is, misery,
whatever the hell her name was.
Yeah.
I hope.
What else are they supposed to do?
He's been a good guy for 100 fucking
years and I'm gonna tell you right now you
fucking comic, but I'm gonna.
I'm going to read the rest of us.
You guys have I, you know, out of
respect. I'll read the last few.
Okay,
sentences here he goes,
I'm not a staunch Republican.
The fuck did my screen go. I'm not a
staunch republican Earl wild southerner.
I'm just a guy who is tired
of this self hating trend.
What's with people are hating tradition
so much that they can't stand a hero.
Just being a hero. Oh, I see. You went
a different direction. This is good.
Why read it? Okay. I think you'd
like some of the newer comic titles,
pictures and words and some good stories
makes for an easy, stimulating read.
Just don't read Captain
America. Love you. Love Nia.
Congrats on the little weighty.
Thank you,
sir. What's your dealing with? The here
is money. That's why they're doing it.
They have exhausted every fucking
possible story, storyline.
You know what I mean?
Like,
do you remember the Brady bunch when they
had to bring in all of Oliver? Right?
Remember like Weber happy days? Like after
a while, like Ron Howard, g, d they just,
he just left. It's just like there's
nothing left to do with this character.
I'm Outta here.
And also the Fonzi started wearing suits
and he was teaching a mechanic class.
He became a teacher. It's fucking
hooligan, riding a motorcycle.
Next thing.
Now he's pulling up in a station wagon
teaching this fucking guy with blonde
hair.
Okay.
How to fucking to the carburetor. He's
actually helping them with their problems.
All of a sudden it
became like welcome back.
Kotter is cause they were out of
ideas that it had run its course.
And I hate to tell you this, but captain
America has run its fucking course.
All right? They're going to get
themselves out of this. All right?
Don't do the classic thing that,
you know,
it wasn't actually the real captain
America, it was fucking somebody else.
But the thing is, dude, um, you are,
you who you should really blame is,
is Al Gore.
He's the reason that this is all
going down because as we all know,
Al Gore invented the Internet.
He said it himself,
he said it himself and he said it again.
All right.
The man invented the Internet
and the Internet, you know,
gave birth to fucking Napster,
which gave birth to all of these things
where people could watch movies and shit
for free. Right? Napster obviously
was music, but the other shit,
people go on Pirate Bay,
they just watch all these movies for free.
So what happened was that killed,
okay,
the fucking 30 to $70 million movies,
like they just went away.
So then everything became either super
fucking cheap or $100 million Superhero
fucking movie where it's like,
all right,
we're going to just spend all this
money and people are going to go,
cause they're gonna want to see special
effects in, you know, at the movie screen.
That's what happens.
So,
and they made 9,000 of
these fucking movies and um,
there's nowhere else to go with them.
I think they made a couple of
captain America movies. Didn't,
I don't fucking know.
But now what they're going to do is
they're going to set this up that now this
guy is actually a fucking
Nazi, you know? And uh,
who was doing all this great stuff
in America? I don't understand.
He was like saving children
while spying on us.
I don't know that they could somehow
going to try to explain all of that shit.
I have no idea. But eventually he's
going to fight Batman. All right?
We all know that Batman
has one professional fight
under his belt and he's all
for one, right? He lost a superman.
So before he gets another
shot at the title,
I think he has to fight somebody else.
Who's he going to fight? You know,
it can't be Lex Luther and
in fucking the octopus guy.
I mean those guys that played out
all right, they're all punch drunk.
Spiderman has been fucking them up
for years if they need somebody. Nope.
So this is the only way to go.
All right?
I would be surprised if Vince McMahon
does not sue them for this storyline
because he did this with Hulk
Hogan like 50 times. You know,
you knew how Kogan was was you
knew when he was the bad guy.
I love because he would
die this side of his beard.
He would die that fucking black and
then he would have the fucking blonde
mustache, which by the way,
I thought looked really cool.
He had a great fucking fool
man show. He still does. Um,
do you ever see guy go bald
more gracefully than that?
He just kept pushing it back like Richard
Rawlings and every time he did it,
it was a little further back,
you know?
Then he started wearing
the fucking the scarves.
Okay.
And always come off in each, I dunno.
Tanned his head up. He looked great.
Then when you say that, how Kogan went
bald very gracefully. What'd you say?
Yeah.
You don't think so? What's wrong with
you today? I feel like you don't like me.
Well, I mean, part of being married,
some days you're not going to like me.
I feel like that's one of these days.
No,
I don't understand how you're
so loud with slippers on.
She just said, that's why I don't like
you. All right, princess Kate fines.
Parenting hard.
Well, I imagine when they try to
play hide and go seek in that castle,
what's going to take forever? Hey Bill,
get a lot of this crap. Kate Middleton,
a fucking princess did his speech in
which she says she's finds it hard being a
mom. Now I'm sure she has a busy schedule
for Christ's sake. She has servants.
I, she doesn't even have
nannies. She has servants. She,
it may have one of the easiest
jobs in the entire world.
She wasn't born to royalty.
She married into it.
So all she needs to do is not be
a con for the next 50 to 75 years.
Stay married and she's all set.
Attached is a link to her full speech.
You can listen to it. Uh,
if you care to listen to it.
I'm not listening to the shit. She's
trying to promote mental health awareness,
which is nice.
But did she really need to try to tell
us that she finds parenting difficult?
Huge fan from Newfoundland,
Canada. Thanks. And don't
forget to go fuck yourself.
Um, yeah. I mean, you
know, this is the thing,
when a kid comes into your life,
there's an adjustment period.
So she was sitting there getting fan by
feathers and all of that shit. Right.
Having somebody bring
her old Dagwood sandwich.
Is she sitting on, you know, the
little Louis, the 15th fucking,
I dunno Ottoman. Is that a word?
Is that a piece of furniture?
It is, isn't it? Or is
that an empire? Um, yeah.
Then all of a sudden the kids there and
she has to pretend to give a fuck about
it. You know, I think it just makes
her photo shoots more difficult.
Okay.
What did she name her kids?
He probably gave him some old
white guy named Winston. Ebenezer.
The fucking 19th or some shit.
Um,
yeah,
the,
I have to be honest with you,
like that has to be the most boring
fucking life you could ever fucking live.
Okay.
Being a fucking princess, at least when
you're a prince, you know, you get the,
he kept fucking guy goes around,
he flies helicopters.
He was in the God damn army.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Goes out. He does shit right tags
out with the boys. He smoked cigars.
What do you do as a princess once
you fucking married? You know,
you broke down on the white horse. She
had your fucking, your wedding, right?
Everybody shows up,
you know,
all the women in the crowd giving you
the evil eye because they wanted to be a
princess. All the haters,
you know, there's,
there's nothing good about that right in,
you know,
cause it's either going to be haters or
people just sobbing because that dream's
never going to happen for them.
So it's how he sees people stare and
stare and fucking daggers at you next to
fatties and fucking Weirdos like,
yeah,
okay.
She's so beautiful.
Um,
I would think it would
be hard to be a princess.
These the mind numbingly boring fucking
life that you're going to live, you know,
to the, to the fuck. This is when you know
your board is when you promote a cause,
you know? Yes. So fucking bored. You
have to go out and help somebody.
It's so fucking all set is not that.
What of, there's nothing to do.
You know? There's nothing
you, we got everything you
fucking want. It's, it's, yeah,
the end game over now. What do
you do now? You got to fucking,
you got to go down to some third world
country and start installing plumbing or
some, but he got it. You
have to do something.
Either that or you just fucking,
you just become like one of
those Dudley Moore characters.
You just get shit faced every day.
Okay.
That's what I would do. Take
up like archery and shit.
I just be in the backyard,
just fucking shoot stuff,
walking around with some
fucking ridiculous cognac.
I would be such a piece of Shit,
you know? I really would be. I I,
if you know it,
can you get written out of the will?
Can you get unfucking prince x
prints or something like that?
Excommunicated from that. I, that's
exactly how I would do, oh my God.
I would have all the fucking sports
packages, I'd go to all the fucking games.
All right. I wouldn't give
a shit either. I would be,
I would be fucking ridiculously
blowing the money and like,
that would be my goal in life.
Like how overt can I be with the English
Tax Pique People's money that they're
there? What am I trying to say? The
English taxpayers' money. There you go.
You ever seen somebody like
dyslexic when they're just talking,
I'll beat you to think I'm trying to read
this shit. I always flip words around.
Um, and by all means, all
of you who aren't doctors,
please diagnose me and tell me what sort
of fish oil and I don't need to take
the cure it. Um, that's what
I would do. I would just like,
my goal would be by the time I'm 42, I
want them to, I could easily do that.
I could easily do that. I could get x
fucking, you know, you no longer at Duke,
you know,
Oh, you know what would be great in order
to be great that people would actually
love you. I want to say we're done. Hate
you. The second you walked into a pub,
you have no more security anymore and
you just come walking in. Oh yeah.
Why you really fucked that one
up then yet be like, yeah, I did.
I had a great time though. The fuck was I
supposed to do? I was living in a castle
you fucking week. You know, that
would be it. The next, you know,
you sitting in the bleachers right in
the fucking pit at the footy games.
Just being a regular guy,
getting fucking hammered,
eating fish and chips and just laughing,
just laughing at how bad you fucked up
your life and all those fucking sad sex.
They'd love you.
Okay.
Um, anyways, fat yoga
instructor. Hey Billy.
Read Sec.
Uh,
I don't know why that struck me so
funny. I mean, I see it every day.
You think that that would be an old joke?
Uh,
I work out here in La as a
personal trainer and teach
some yoga classes here and
there.
Um,
I've been teaching yoga at this studio
for over four years and I got this fat
ass cunt for a manager bill.
She's gotta be 80 pounds overweight.
And despite being around
all this healthy lifestyle,
she has done nothing to improve herself.
I'm talking donuts and cookies in this.
I fucking love this person. Oh my
God. I love both of these people.
I love that you're calling her
out for being fat or him out.
And I love that this person sit there
fucking eating donuts in a yoga,
a yoga shop. What do you
call it? Studio a studio.
A dojo crib.
Uh,
I'm talking donuts and cookies in the
studio lobby around people that are there
to avoid these temptations.
That's fucking hilarious.
Anyways,
I've kept my mouth shut for years,
but recently we had our annual class
review with a manager comes and sees how,
how you class,
how your class is put together
and how you are with the students,
et Cetera. Uh, this whale could even
get through the first 15 minutes.
She was beached on her mat. Belly
was beached on a mat, belly up,
gulping fucking water. Oh, she went
into, yeah, she went into a whale post.
Okay.
Then afterwards she had the nerve
to criticize my class that it wasn't
challenging enough. Oh my God.
And you didn't say anything.
Okay. This is their reason. The grudge is
being held. Okay. The, the, it should say,
the reason, the reason the grudge
is being held is that my aunt,
my annual raise was a mere 30 cents.
And I wonder if that
criticism affected it.
Give me that Billy Berg philosophy on the,
the situation.
Love the pod podcast.
Congratulations on the baby.
It was great hearing her on the podcast
the other day. Uh, go fuck yourself.
Fire Nips.
Um,
Jesus Christ really coming at me with
the fucking red head shit today. Are you?
Um, I, I think the whole
thing is fucking hilarious.
Um, I gotta ask you something. All right?
You've been doing this shit
there for over four years or you,
why don't you eventually start
your own Spec at this point?
You know, get out from that. This is
what, you know what I would do if I was,
you get in a good graces bent,
you know,
just start bringing a donuts.
I bring a fudge, you know,
and just, you know, I don't
know if the cops could prove it,
but you just killer killer with what
she loves. Kill her with kindness.
Okay. There you go. Kill
her with kindness. Just keep
what she got to do. Okay.
And this is the thing about those fatties
is that they can handle donuts are
right, but I'm telling you right now,
nobody can handle fudge. Fudge is like,
it's like an online,
it's almost 100% sugar.
It's like a solid form of cotton
candy with like chocolate in it.
I mean it is fucking, you can't even eat
it. Thank you. I hope face puckers up.
This is what you do. You come
in, you make a tray of fudge,
all right? You cut a piece
out, this is what you do. Okay.
He cut a fucking piece out.
All right. And just, you know,
give it to the birds or some shit.
Right? I think sugar is good for them.
I can't remember it. See good.
Or it kills him either way.
Just give it to the fucking parts,
right?
Then you bring the fudge in this and
now it looks like somebody or he took a
piece that she's not going to feel
guilty and I guaran fucking tee.
I guarantee you do in the sugar is going
to fuck with it. Joints. All right?
Then you come in with some
bacon, some sandwiches. You
just keep going. Sugar, salt,
sugar, salt, sugar, salt. Okay. And just,
you know that 30 cents
they should have given you.
You take 30 another 30 cents out of
your fucking check. Every God damn hour,
all right? And, and you,
you put it towards giving this
person food that'll slowly kill him.
There they go.
Or you get a new job.
I Dunno. I just, I just think killing
her. Be Funny. All right, to Sony,
your daughter a Billy Bathgate's.
Uh,
would you ever disown your daughter if she
brought home a. Dot, dot, dot. Dot. Dot,
dot, dot, dot, dot, dot,
dot, dot. Dot. Hack comic.
Oh Jesus. Think of the hackiest type of
comic you can think of. And in the future,
she brought him home talking about how
she loves him and now he's the funniest
comic ever. Uh, Oh God,
he's got a youtube channel, tells
jokes with the lampshade on his head.
It's Cetera. She asks you
what you think of him. Uh,
you tell her is a hack
she gets mad at you,
tells you you don't understand him
and how he's funnier than you. Uh,
would you dishonor her and tell her she
can't bring the hack into what's out now?
No jokes. Reef. Yeah. Joke thief.
He can't come into the house.
You can't come into my house as
a fucking joke thief. Um, uh,
I, this is what I would do. You know
what? Even even if he stole fucking jokes,
I know he's going to get caught and
people going to call him out on it.
I wouldn't say anything Eric.
Cause I'll tell you this, I,
I've seen how that goes down when you
say you don't like somebody that you kid
likes. You know what I mean? And then
there's all those enlarged problems.
All right, this, this is your job as
a parent is you gotta Trust your kids.
Decisionmaking all right?
They love the guy.
You just got to go with it, you know what
I mean? And then if they get divorced,
you can't be like, hey, you know,
I, I was, you know, cause then,
but why didn't you fucking say something
cause you'd hate me. Um, Jesus,
why would you bring that up? I'm,
I'm just, I'm three months into this.
I want to enjoy my, my daughter
growing up. Jesus Christ.
You already got me the picture
of being at the fucking wedding.
You know, the guy would have some
fucking crazy colored fucking bow tie.
The cumber bun all. Alright. I don't
know Jesus Christ. What a way to end.
Um, by the way, uh, how about the Celtics
not coming back when in two games.
How lucky did we get with Rondo
going down? Jesus Christ, by the way,
he pulled off a short sleeve suit.
I don't know how he did it.
He actually fucking look cool.
I think you had to have a cast on to
make it work though. Like he dead.
He fucked up his thumb assumption. All
Right Patrice, dear Billy, big tits.
Hey, I'm losing weight. You found this
on youtube almost shit myself laughing.
Thought you'd appreciate
this. Some classic hope you
enjoy and go fuck yourself.
I will definitely retweet this. Um,
thank you for sending that in. Um,
you know, it's always great that people
are still watching his shit and uh,
I'm always talking about them and that
type of stuff. It keeps his comedy alive.
I know that's all cliched stuff.
But like I was talking to,
I was actually talking to Bart,
Nick and Andrew last night about them and
the green room and I was just talking,
just saying how,
um,
just what a fucking just
still like crater comedy.
Fucking crater. What a fucking
lost that was, man. It's just, uh,
that guy was so much,
he was so much better than all of us.
It was fucking ridiculous.
And um,
okay.
I'm telling you, even in, even as
great as elephant in the room is,
I'm telling you he's,
he effortlessly cook.
His next special would've been at least
fucking 30% funnier than that one.
That's the trajectory
that that guy was on.
And I'm a fucking kills me, man.
Fucking kills me. So anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Uh, please check out. Return to
the Mac. The first couple episodes,
it's streaming on something. I don't
fucking know anymore. Um, very funny.
My apologies to John McIntyre
for standing up last week.
I really fucked that up and he couldn't,
you know,
it was the worst part and he was
totally cool about it because no one,
no worries brother. Fuck it. Don't worry
about it and all that. That was the worst.
I was like, can you at least be mad at me?
Something? All right, go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.